it's nice to be here I actually started
out doing magic or as my dad called it
gay weirdest gig ever did was a magic
gig I was in high school this guy called
me up he's like can you do a magic show
for the deaf I was like yeah that's the
easiest magic show I will ever do and it
was right because he just had them pick
cards like I'm gonna turn around you
show everybody then my friend in the
back just screamed out I just found out
that the world record for most times
being hit by lightning and surviving is
7
did you guys know that a dude was hit by
and survived lightning seven times his
name was Roy Sullivan he's born in
Virginia in 1912 he was an American hell
yeah cuz we're like 36 in math and 24th
and reading but we are number one
impersonal lightning strikes us take you
seven times I did that joke in Australia
some guy in the audience was like in a
row
no that's not a record you ain't just
lying on the floor just like lightning
lightning lightning Wow why record no
seven separate times over the course of
a miserable horrific ly unlucky life can
you imagine what a journey what an
emotional journey if you like the first
time to get hit by lightning you're
probably just like surprised right you
got hit you're just like hey was that
lightning someone's like yeah you're
missing an eyebrow and you [ __ ] your
pants
so yes enlightenment second time you get
hit you're like what are the odds
but like the third or fourth time though
I just like this is Who I am
I'm lightning wrong master of lightning
by the fifth time anger terror somebody
goes to take a picture of you the flash
goes off you think it's lightning you
curl up in a corner you're like not
again not again why am I so bad at
outside but like the sixth or seventh
I'm like I think I have a superpower but
I have no idea how to use it how would
you like me to help people what would
you like me to do just like hug a
murderer and wait
just grab ahold of a murdery looking
fella he's like like schuftis his coming
wait for him seven times he was hit by
and survived lightning seven times
and at the age of 71 he killed himself
yeah I don't think he was depressed I
just think he wanted to show God that
it's not that hard
she was trip to heaven look out right in
the face be like nailed it first try
score 7 1 that's a blowout he was 71 I'm
31 anybody here in their 30s couple
people willing to admit that in
Hollywood good for you it's weird I
remember as a kid playing Tetris that
was the only video game Russia ever
released that's an amazing thing right
considering they were competing with
Japan and they were coming out with
video games like every two seconds right
they were amazing even in the 80s
they're like America check this out
Italian plumber goes to a kingdom eats
mushrooms crushes Turtles gets in a
dinosaur save the princess defeats a
dragon and the Russians were like books
organized blocks
is that the whole game no no if you do a
good job we take away the books how do
you beat this game it's like life in
Russia you lose or you die these are the
options game goes on forever - you give
up and kill yourself this is life in
Russia you're welcome
technology's gotten better than right
like we're going to Mars you guys know
that we go to Mars yeah and we only know
how to get them there it's a one-way
trip and there's still people who want
to do it there's a hundred finalists for
a one-way trip to Mars you can read
about them one of them's a 23 year old
girl she's quoted in The New Yorker as
saying I am so excited and my boyfriend
is so supportive honey he's breaking up
with you
like he's literally counting down to the
cleanest breakup in human history
he's a genius or hate he's gonna be stay
on that launchpad like I love you
ten-nine I'm dating your sister last up
you guys been great thanks so much
everybody
[Applause]
you